bien bon
vous racontez une histoire d'amour il
des histoires d'amour tout le monde
envie il y en a plein donc je suis assez
content de la mienne et cette histoire
d'amour fonds va être franc est là
franchement démarré comme toutes les
histoires d'amour c'est à dire que
j'étais un petit peu intimidé j'avais
peur de l'approcher et enfin quand j'ai
réussi à vaincre ma timidité
pour être franc avec vous j'avais un
petit peu de mal à être avec parce que
chaque fois qu'on était ensemble et bien
les gens nous regardaient d'une manière
un peu particulière nous dévisager
beaucoup et on peut les comprendre parce
qu'il est impressionnant il fait de se
mettre 10 donc c'était pas facile je
pense que cette histoire d'amour aussi
dans ma famille elle a été compliqué
parce que mes parents comme tous les
parents il avait forcément envie un jour
d'être grands-parents et évidemment avec
un aigle
c'était pas possible donc je suis pas
tombé amoureux quand même de n'importe
quel aigles je suis tombé amoureux du
plus grand aigle d'europe le pygargue à
queue blanche un oiseau qui peut faire
jusqu'à deux mètres cinquante
d'envergure qu'on appelait au moyen-âge
leur ferait pousser des cris d'orfraie
vient d'ailleurs de cet oiseau qui est
un cri extrêmement strident où on la
période de reproduction
et si je vous dis ça c'est tout
simplement pour faire comprendre que si
un animal réussi à donner une expression
populaire c'est qu'il est extrêmement
courant c'est-à-dire qu'on le trouve
partout dans la quand même réussi un
exploit nous les français on a réussi
entre 1820 et 1840 à tuer un par un
jusqu'au dernier tous les pygargue à
queue blanche qui existait en france
parce qu'on avait décidé à cette époque
là qu'ils avaient des espèces utiles et
des espèces nuisibles
il avait été classé dans les espèces
nuisibles c'était un gros d'oiseaux qui
volait pas très vite c'était pas un coup
de fusil très difficile donc il a été
complètement éradiquée en vingt ans j'ai
découvert donc cet oiseau mois dans la
littérature en fait atteint dans notre
look suisse s'appelle paul géroudet qui
écrivait très bien et qui a écrit cette
phrase qui m'est restée depuis mes 12
ans j'écrivais je vois passer ce géant
devant moi peut-être ne s'est-il pas
méthyle le dernier de son espèce et je
sais pas pourquoi cette phrase m'a
marqué je me suis toujours promis
emma des gens moins d'en voir un dans ma
vie et puis peut-être un jour faire
quelque chose pour eux est effectivement
le jour où j'ai rencontré mon premier
pays à queue blanche c'était vraiment
une histoire d'amour et j'ai voulu
essayer d'abord dans un premier temps de
les sauver en les reproduisant captivité
et dans un même temps mon idée c'était
de leur remettre dans la nature en
france et je me suis aperçu d'une chose
c'est qu'un oiseau qui est né en
captivité ne sait pas voler ça peut vous
paraître bizarre qui est né en captivité
c'est se déplacer jallet d'un point a à
un point b en battant des ailes comme
n'importe quel oiseau ça ils savent tous
le faire mais voler c'est utiliser le
vent il ya notamment dans la nature ce
qu'on appelle des thermiques des vents
qui vont des colonnes d'air chaud on a
dû dynamique du thermodynamique diktats
a bâti un bref il ya plein de vent et ça
dans la nature en fait ce sont les
parents qui vont apprendre aux oiseaux à
utiliser ce vent évidemment un animal
qui est né en captivité n'a pas eu la
chance de faire cet apprentissage
je me suis donc un peu involontairement
mais transformé en une sorte de coach
sportif pour règle ça vous fait rire
mais vous allez voir derrière sur
l'écran qui va apparaître ici je fais
avec mes règles du parapente
je fais avec mes règles du ski ça c'est
plutôt pour l'hiver dans le montagne je
fais en est et du kayak du vélo de la
randonnée enfin bref plein de choses
avec mes règles
tout ça pour pouvoir partager cet espace
et leur apprendre à voler et je vais
vous raconter une première anecdote qui
m arrive et jeté à morzine
donc je décolle juste au dessus de
morzine en parapente avec mon
et puis malheureusement le vent se lève
mauvais vent
l'oiseau lui n'est pas trop embêté et
continue à voler mais moi je suis obligé
de me poser en urgence
enfin le temps d'aller poser de plier la
voile loiseau a disparu je le trouve
plus et je retournais vers la voiture je
reçois un petit coup de téléphone et
c'était les pompiers team usa jacques
olivier on a retrouvé son aigle et la
lave est de la manche dépêche toi ils
t'attendent là bas ça arrivait quand
même assez souvent que les pertes donc
il me connaissait
je me dirige à la vallée de la manche
j'arrive village euros borde la route
six pompiers de gendarmes
viège a colligé ton aigles il est rentré
dans la maison et tout il y avait une
dame sur le bord de la route j'ai oublié
de préciser qui était en robe de chambre
et me renseigne un peu et en fait je
comprends l'explication donc la dame
m'explique en fait elle était en train
de prendre son petit déjeuner dans son
chalet avait laissé la baie vitrée
ouverte il y avait son chat qui se
faisait bronzer sur le balcon
l'aigle depuis l'eau évidemment à vue le
chat a eu l'idée d'essayer de manger le
chat donc est rentré par l'abbé vie très
fin dans deux mètres qui rentrent avec
le chat est rentré d'abord l'aigle
derrière évidemment la dame quand elle a
vu rentrer l'aigle a quitté tout de
suite sa table est sorti en courant en
robe de chambre dans la rue et accès met
à crier et alerté les voisins les
pompiers enfin bref donc j'étais pas je
ne brillait pas enfin je rentre quand
même dans le chalet et là je retrouve il
s'appelait sherkan qui était posée sur
une paire de babouches de la dame venait
de ramener du maroc et c'était du cuir
donc ça ressemblait à mon gant et donc
qu'ils servent et s'étaient installés là
assez tranquillement je ressors avec
l'aigle je m'excuse auprès de la dame
tout sa fin et le gendarme me dit non
mais là j'ai publié ça va pas aller ça
devient grave on t'envoie au tribunal
pour divagation d'animal il se passe
quand même là à ce moment là quinze
jours trois semaines avant que soit
convoqué un peu plus même d'ailleurs au
tribunal et je me retrouve devant un
tribunal devant le juge qui visiblement
voient en moi un fou furieux il dit mais
comment vous pouvez laisser une bête
pareil qui risque de tuer tout le monde
vole et avec vous vous êtes inconscient
et là je m'aperçois en fait que ce juge
il est comme vous
jean il a une vision totalement erronée
et donc je lui explique en fait un
phénomène qui est simple c'est que c'est
wade c'est pygargue à tête blanche on
connaissait tous est l'emblème des états
unis ils ont choisi l'aigle comme onze
autres pays dans le monde comme je sais
plus combien de multinationales et
autres et on a un petit peu oublié ça
donc je rappelle sa aux présidents et
présidentes du musette surgit mais côté
monsieur le président c'est assez simple
c'est lié à deux phénomènes
le premier c'est que on s'est coupé de
la nature c'est à dire que le président
de l'époque américain avait bien vu lui
parce qu'il allait encore un petit peu
dans la nature qu'il avait des aigles
autour de lui qu'il était le vrai
comportement de l'aig aujourd'hui plus
personne voit les aides dont on a
complètement oublié leur comportement on
n'est pas aidés en cela par deux choses
la première c'est les médias et je le
dis avec d'autant plus de facilité que
je passe ma vie à faire des
documentaires pour la télé et je veux
vous assurer que malheureusement on vous
ment dans les documentaires animaliers
que vous voyez et je vais en prendre
deux exemples
un de mes amis a fait vous l'avez
peut-être vu le documentaire sur bonobos
vous savez le singe qui chaque fois
qu'il a une querelle rex en conflit par
une relation sexuelle toujours très
intéressant il fait un film d'une heure
et demie le présente à son distributeur
lui dit mais tu es fou peut pas montrer
ça aux enfants
donc est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
refait tout le film et pendant une heure
et demie vous avez un film sur les
bonobos sans sexe un peu bizarre pour
expliquer le comportement de l'épaisse
l'espèce il ya deux ans je réalise moi
même un film sur les aigles appelé
freedom je prends montre à la chaîne de
télévision le résultat final il
jacques olivier thémines scènes de
chasse bah oui c'est un aigle ah oui
mais non et 5 portes et publics font
lever toutes les scènes de chasse donc
j'ai fait aussi moi un film sur les ex
sans chasse donc c'est pour vous dire
que d'un côté on nous aide pas à
comprendre ça et même les scientifiques
s'y met c'est à dire que les
scientifiques si vous regardez sur la
page de l'aigle ils vous disent l'aigle
est un klepto parasites assez compliqué
ça veut juste dire qui pique sa proie
aux autres donc tout ça vous éloigne de
ces animaux et donc vous n'avez plus la
vraie notion de ce qu'est un aigle et le
président finalement au bout de mon
petit quart d'heure d'explication me dit
vous n'êtes pas un fou furieux vous
allez tout temps les quatre hot docs que
l'air de connaître votre affaire je vais
donc vous laisser continuer à voler avec
wozzeck par contre je vous mettrais
quand même 150 euros damende pour
justifier mon déplacement dont j'ai payé
mes 150 euros d'amendé
deuxième épisode ça se passe il ya
quatre ans je reçois un coup de fil d'un
journaliste qui me dit à monsieur
travers un truc incroyable ya un mec qui
devenu fou alors je sais pas si vous
connaissez toute la difficulté
aujourd'hui à définir ce que c'est que
la folie animal en avons une vraie
discussion les spécialistes entre ceux
qui disent les anciens écoliers ça
n'existe pas ce sont plus des
comportements déviants il ya la
captivité
et puis d'autres qui disent s'il ya une
vraie folie animaliers les animaux qui
vraiment ont des névroses
alors je veux pas rentrer dans ce débat
là mais je lui dis alors quel type de
folie a atteint c'était qu à écouter il
a attaqué un chat et mangé un chat son
stade de la pontaise en plein lausanne
on a des photos en un film je t'ai bonsu
peut être enfin je vois rien de très
anormal ascain aigles attaquent y mange
un chat là je sens que j'ai perdu
quelques années alors je voudrais quand
même vous poser une petite question
est-ce que parmi vous quelqu'un peut me
rappeler
al'inverse combien d'oiseaux sont mangés
chaque année par les chats en france je
voudrais trois chiffres vous propose 2
millions 20 millions ou 200 millions
allaient venir
j'aurais été sur et bien sachez que
c'est en france 1 200 millions d'oiseaux
mangés par les chats en france 3,7
milliards aux états unis je ne sais pas
si vous imaginez l'hécatombe donc qu'ils
aient quelques chats qui se fâche mangés
par les aigles
ça me traumatise pas plus que ça alors
cela dit j'ai décidé de creuser un petit
peu l'idée quand même parce que ça m'a
intéressé et j'ai appelé quelques uns de
mes amis écolos en leur demandant mais
quelle est la réalité sur le terrain
parce que j'entends parler de trois
trucs j'ai vu même que mon chat courait
après à la bouche et mon oeil court
après un chat il a écouté jacques
olivier on vient de faire une étude
justement sur le couple qui nichent
juste au dessus de la ville de briançon
et selon les périodes de l'année c'est
30% son régime alimentaire qui
composaient déjà de la ville ça fait
quelques-uns qu'en mer et
on a des réunions dans la foulée qui sur
le plan de sauvegarde de l'aigle enfance
et gens disent il faut absolument
continuer à sauver les gens
je vais quand même vous rappeler que
l'aigle autrefois il ya 200 ans vivait
en france en trouver dans la plaine de
la beauce
on l'a chassé exterminer il est allé se
réfugier dans les montagnes on l'a
protégée à partir 1976 il est passé de
1700 mètres de nidification à moins de
900 m simplement ce qui s'est passé
entre temps c'est que il ya 200 ans
quand il était dans la plaine de la
beauce y avait personne quasiment et on
avait pas d'animaux domestiques
aujourd'hui la vie a totalement changé
l'expansion humaine fait qu'on a des
habitants partent ou quasiment
et surtout on a des animaux domestiques
énormément et donc j'essaie d'expliquer
à mes copains écolo jean dit si on
continue comme ça à laisser descendre
volontairement à l'aigle royal
on va avoir un vrai problème c'est à
dire qu'ils vont tuer des chats il va
tuer les chiens et les gens aujourd'hui
on est dans une société d'émotion on
n'est pas dans ceux de raisonnement
quand votre chat va se faire manger par
un aigle et je vous comprendrez vous
aime bien mais nous on veut plus des
aigles et le problème c'est que l'aigle
dans notre jargon c'est ce qu'on appelle
une espèce parapluie
c'est une espèce qui à partir de
laquelle parce qu'elle est emblématique
on a réussi à protéger toutes les autres
espèces de rapaces aujourd'hui en france
tous les rapaces en protéger au départ
on a obtenu ceci grâce à la protection
des glo royal si un jour la protection
sous la pression populaire de l'aigle
royal tombe c'est la protection de tous
les rapaces qui va tomber
donc ça sera complètement
contre-productif et je dis toujours
quand on aime quelqu'un c'est pas lui
laisser tout faire et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer mes amis écolos c'est que
c'est bien qu'ils restent en montagne
qu'on le laisse au dessus de 1000 mètres
d'altitude où il n'y a pas trop de monde
pas trop d'animaux domestiques c'est
bien des killers descendre on va avoir
un problème
et pour en revenir à mon histoire de
départ d'une histoire d'amour
ce que je voulais vous dire c'est que
toute histoire d'amour elle à deux
écueils principaux le premier c'est
l'idéalisation c'était ma première
histoire c'est à dire que on idéalise
l'être aimé comme mon juge idéalisé
l'aigle dans un animal qu'il n'était pas
la deuxième de deuxième danger d'une
histoire d'amour c'est
l'intellectualisation ou la
rationalisation à l'extrême c'est dire
que vous n'avez pas une femme ou un
homme peu importe parce que il vous fait
il vous créez des papillons dans le vent
mais voulait mais parce que ses enfants
ont le même âge que les vôtres parce que
sa maison est pas très loin de la vôtre
parce qu'ils aiment la même voiture que
la vôtre fin bref pour des
considérations qui n'ont rien à voir
avec l'amour et ça c'est les deux
écueils
simplement nous les humains on a inventé
quelque chose qui est pratique c'est que
notre tonton d'enceinte ces deux écueils
le problème c'est qu'avec la faune
sauvage on pourra pas divorcer on pourra
pas un jour décidé de faire la garde
alternée de notre enfant commun qui est
la planète
donc il va bien falloir qu'on apprenne à
vivre ensemble avec ses animaux et je
pense que d'ici 10 ans peut-être qu'un
jour il ya un aigle qui va venir se
poser à côté de chez vous ou sur votre
maison
la première chose j'espère d'abord que
vous le regardez vraiment parce que
c'est un animal qui extraordinaire vrai
c'est une des plus belles créatures de
la planète mais j'aimerais que vous
n'oubliez pas à ce moment là aussi que
peut-être il aura envie de manger votre
char et il le fera pas parce qu'ils vous
aiment pas il le fera pas parce qu'il
est méchant
il ne fera pas non plus parce qu'il est
devenu fou il le fera simplement parce
qu'il a un prédateur et qu'un prédateur
ça tu es qu'un aigle vous va être autre
chose que ce qu'il est et ça je crois
que si on veut un jour apprendre à vivre
avec les prédateurs à côté de nous
c'est comme quand on aime quelqu'un il
faut apprendre à lui avec ses défauts
aussi avec ils ont leurs défauts celui
ci en est un il risque effectivement de
perturber un petit peu l'autre mode de
vieques nos animaux domestiques
par contre je ne veux pas faire ce vague
cela j'ai peur j'espère vous avoir
tétanisé avec les aigles
je ne veux pas conclure ce propos sans
vous rappeler qu'un aigle n'attaque
jamais l'être humain et je sais que dans
cette salle certains ne vont pas me
croire
alors j'ai pensé qu' une belle image
veulent est beaucoup mieux qu'un long
discours dont je vais vous proposer
aujourd'hui de faire une rencontre un
petit peu particulière je vous ai amené
un de mes règles et je vais le faire
voler juste au dessus de vos têtes dont
vous mangerez vraiment de ne pas bouger
laissez-le bien faire vous allez voir un
de ses fameux pygargue à tête blanche de
voir cette espèce qu'on a quand même
réussi à tuer en l'espace de 20 ans tu
peux rentrer tranquillement et on va le
laisser tranquillement me rejoindre
n'est ce pas tant opus love le qui me
regarde je me regarde et me fait ch
voilà c'est cet oiseau qu'on a quand
même réussi à exterminer
alors celui ci est un mâle adulte ca de
2 mètres 10 d'envergure qui fait 4 kg on
voudra passer un petit bout de la tête
quand même alors il est âgé de 8 ans et
comme tous les aigles il a quand même
quelques petites particularités que je
vais vous mentionnez je voulais dit que
c'était ce son pardon des animaux tout à
fait exceptionnel alors la première
chose on dit avoir une vue d'aigle ça
c'est pas usurpée cet oiseau voit tout
simplement des cantons touchés plus en
face de lumière pour être tout
simplement dix fois mieux que nous à
l'autre comme celui ci est capable de me
repérer en plein ciel jusqu'à quatre
kilomètres de distance si vous vouliez
voir aussi bien que cet oiseau est bien
il faudrait tout simplement que vos yeux
dans votre tête et la taille d'une
orange et vous verriez à peu près comme
c'était gai celui ci a 8 ans je voulais
dire également sanogo qui va vivre en
captivité jusqu'à 50 ans donc sans eau
qui jugent extrêmement vieux par contre
qui on qui ne sont adultes qu à
l'ajustement de 6 à 7 ans qui ne font
que 1 à 2 petits par an donc c'est pour
ça qu'ils évidemment il faut continuer
la protection ces oiseaux
alors j'espère ma foi que quand les
vents ayant vu d'aussi près je vous en
aurez convaincu surtout vous aurez
définitivement convaincu que ce ne sont
pas des cruel et sanguinaire mais
simplement des prédateurs qui ont leur
rôle à jouer dans notre environnement
merci à vous et je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée merci beaucoup